c'est
bon tu veux bien fermer la
porte bien alors nous allons continuer
nos nos auditions dans le cadre de
l'examen du pfss donc nous recevons à
présent Monsieur Thomas casenu ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics donc
sur le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale j'indique de nouveau
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site du Sénat et disponible à la
demande monsieur le ministre je vais
tout d'abord vous laisser présenter ce
pfss en particulier ces équilibres
généraux et les mesures envisagé en
matière de recettes à cet égard tout de
même en introduction notre commission
s'interroge notamment sur la trajectoire
financière
cadrienale que présente ce projet de loi
et sur sa compatibilité avec une
extension de la dette sociale à
l'horizon 2033 nous aurons aussi
l'occasion certainement d'évoquer avec
vous votre position concernant les
relations lunedic et la JIC Carco
et bien entendu après votre intervention
je donnerai la parole en premierieu à
notre rapporteur généralisabeth douanau
puis aux sénateurs qui souhaiteront vous
questionner sur le budget voilà monsieur
le ministre c'est la parole est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur général voilà je vous
cherchis du regard Mesdames et Messieurs
les les sénateurs je je suis heureux de
de vous
présenter ce projet loi de de
financement de la Sécurité social dont
dont mon collègue mes collègues Aurélien
Rousseau et Aurore berger vous ont déjà
présenté les les principales mesures et
je souhaiterais pour répondre à à votre
interrogation insister sur les grands
équilibres les grands équilibres
financiers du PLFSS et sur quelques
mesures essentielles concernant les
recettes de la sécurité sociale je
souhaitrais d'abord revenir sur le
cadrage financier proposé par ce projet
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale alors il s'inscrit dans une
trajectoire vous le savez plus large
celle que nous avons proposé dans le
projet loi de de programmation des
finances publiques l'objectif est de
parvenir d'ici 2027 à une réduction de
notre déficit en dessous du seuil des 3
%. il en va de la soutenabilité de notre
système et l'ensemble des
administrations dont la sécurité sociale
doit y contribuer c'est la raison pour
laquelle le PLFSS qui vous a proposé
poursuit l'investissement massif pour la
sécurité sociale dans le champ par
exemple de la santé de l'accès au
médicaments de l'autonomie ainsi le
PLFSS prévoit pour 2024 plus de 640
milliards d'euros de dépense en hausse
et j'insiste làdus en hausse de 30
milliards d'euros par rapport à
2023 cette augmentation s'explique
notamment par le mécanisme protecteur
d'indexation des prestations sur
l'inflation qui représente 14 milliards
d'euros pour les retraites par exemple
tout en poursuivant cet investissement
pour la sécurité sociale le PLF FSS
prévoit d'importantes économies la
construction de longondam 2024 en est
une parfaite illustration nous prévoyons
en effet une rectification de longam
2023 de 2,8 milliards d'euros une
progression de longam 2024 de 3,2 % soit
un niveau très largement supérieur à
l'inflation qui devrait quant à elle
s'élever à 2,5 %. la hausse des dépenses
en 2024 concernera en particulier le
secteur hospitalier puisque pour la 2uxè
année consécutive l'ONDAM hospitalierp
dépassera les 100 milliards d'euros sous
un niveau historique l'ONDAM
médico-social représentera quant à lui
plus de 30 milliards
d'euros plus précisément pour 2023 la
rectification de longam permettra de
financer les revalorisations salariales
en faveur des professionnels de nos
établissements sanitaires et médicaux
sociaux il s'agit d'un effort inédit la
révision à la Haus de longam permettra
aussi d'abonder le fond fond d'urgence
pour les éepades annoncé par la première
ministre cet été qui disposera ainsi de
100 millions d'euros pour accompagner
les établissements en difficultés pour
2024 les revalorisations salariales
prendront effet sur toute l'année et
représenteront 6,2 milliards d'euros qui
viennent s'ajouter au 10,9 milliards
d'euros déjà prévus par le Ségure de la
santé l'ONDAM permettra aussi de
soutenir la branche autonomie en
prévoyant les moyens nécessaires à la
création des 6000 ETP supplémentaires en
épad il s'agira aussi de financer la
mise en place progressive des 50000
solutions pour les personnes en
situation de handicap dont le coût sera
de 1,5 milliards d'euros d'ici 2030 pour
la branche autonomie nous créons enfin
en 2024 les plateformes de repérage et
d'orientation précoce des enfants en
situation de handicap il ne s'agit donc
pas de diminuer les dépense mais de
maîtriser leur progression cette
maîtrise et dépens sera assurée par
plusieurs leviers qui qui représente 3,5
milliard d'euros d'économie au titre
d'un effort partagé entre tous les
acteurs du système de
santé 1,3 milliards d'euros d'économie
sont attendus des produits de santé soit
1 milliard d'euros au titre de la baisse
des prix négocié avec les industriel et
300 millions d'euros du fait de la
baisse des volumes pour y parvenir
plusieurs mesures sont prévues au niveau
législatif euh dans le PLF SS il s'agit
de permettre par exemple la délivrance
par les pharmacien de certains
médicaments sous réserve de la
réalisation d'un test en confirmant
l'utilité 1,3 milliard d'euros
d'économie aussi correspondent à des
efforts demandés aux assurés à leur
complémentaires dans une logique
d'efficience mais aussi de lutte contre
les gaspillages différentes options
peuvent être envisagées et nécessitent
encore d'être discuté et concerté 900
millions d'euros enfin d'économie lié
aux soins de ville à l'hôpital et aux
établissements médicaux sociaux en
particulier l'amélioration de l'
efficience à l'hôpital et dans le
secteur médico-social via la politique
d'achat et d'amélioration de la
pertinence et de l'efficience des soins
devra permettre de réaliser 600 millions
d'euros d'économie ces économies
répondent à des enjeux financiers mais
aussi sanitaires et environnementaux
concernant par exemple les médicaments
ils représentent 4 % des émissions de
carbone en France et la réduction de
leur consommation représente donc aussi
un levier pour notre combat en faveur de
la transition écologique nous nous
construisons ainsi une trajectoire
graduelle de rétablissement des comptes
cette trajectoire passe aussi par des
mesures en recette et par la
préservation des économies issues des
réformes passées je pense notamment aux
réformes de l'assurance chômage et des
retraites porté par mon collègue Olivier
duopt je souhaite à ce titre refaire le
point sur les mesures du texte et
d'évoquer l'impact de mesures nouvelles
introduites à l'Assemblée nationale
s'agissant de l'agir Carco comme j'ai pu
le dire à l'Assemblée nationale nous
conservons l'objectif de sanctuariser
les les économies pour financer des
dispositifs de solidarité du système de
retraite et souhaitons avancer par la
voie du dialogue social sur la base de
l'article 9 de la ni et je me réjouis
d'ailleurs fortement que les
organisations patronal dans leur
ensemble est désormais fait part de leur
souhait d'ouvrir les discussions sur le
sujet je souhaitais également euh
pointer euh l'article 8 du PLFSS qui
revient sur le transfert aux URSAF du
recouvrement des cotisations retraite
complémentaires qui devait avoir lieu en
2024 vous en aviez d'ailleurs souligné
les risques dans un rapport de la
mission d'évaluation et de contrôle des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale en 2022 et après le report que
vous aviez préconisé et que nous avons
mis en œuvre en 2023 nous avons
désormais fait le choix du maintien d'un
circuit
spécifique la discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale nous a permis d'introduire
deux mesures très importantes sur
lesquelles je souhaitais revenir le gel
des points de sortie des allègements
généraux et la réforme de l'assiette des
cotisations et contributions des
travailleurs indépendants nous allons
d'ailleurs nous attacher à déposer un
amendement portant actualisation des
annexes financières du PLFSS pour que
vous ayez la juste vue de l'impact
financier de ces mesures au-delà de mon
intervention de cet après-midi pour
sécuriser la réduction de notre déficit
public dès 2024 nous avons ainsi
introduit dans le PLFSS à l'occasion des
débat à l'Assemblée une mesure de gel
des barêes des allègements généraux nous
stabiliserons les barêes à leur niveau
de
2023 s'agissant des bornes de 2,5 SMIC
et 3,5 SMIC ce qui évitera une Perre de
recettes de l'ordre de 600 million
d'euros pour la sécurité sociale comme
vous le savez nous sommes très prudents
sur l'évolution de ces exonérations en
effet il s'agit d'un déterminant
essentiel du coût du travail que nous
avons cherché à abaisser tant que
possible dans une logique à la fois de
compétitivité et d'amélioration du
revenu net des salariés aujourd'hui
cependant comp tenu de la très forte
dynamique du SMIC en lien avec
l'inflation le montant des allaigements
a a augmenté de manière considérable il
devrait coûter 80 milliards d'euros en
2024 la structure de ces allègements
s'est également déformée au profit des
salaires moyens ou élevés dans la
distribution alors même que leur
efficacité est plus élevé pour les
salaires les moins élevés ainsi le
dispositif de gel permettra d'une part
de modérer la dynamique d'exonération et
d'autre part de préserver le montant
global des réductions accordées aux
employeurs ainsi que la répartition
entre les secteur économique concerné ce
qui donne toute la visibilité la
prévisibilité nécessaire aux entreprises
la deuxième mesure que nous avons
introduite et la réforme de l'assiette
des cotisations et contribution des
travailleurs indépendants grande réforme
de simplification administrative il
s'agit surtout d'une réforme créatrice
de droits sociaux nouveaux l'ambition
est d'améliorer les droits à la retraite
des travailleurs indépendants du fait de
la reconfiguration des contributions et
cotisations leur CSG diminuera et leur
assiette de cotisation augmentera c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs cette réforme a
recueilli le plein soutien de l'UDP de
la CPME étroitement concerté le projet
qui vous est soumis est le fruit
d'échang nombreux et correspond à des
modifications substantielles de la
proposition initiale du gouvernement ce
gain sera fonction de la majoration des
cotisations de retraite complémentaires
à laquelle procéderont les différents
régimes professionnels et du rendement
des droits acquis au sein de ces régimes
le cadrage de la réforme impose une
neutralité financière globale elle
illustre notre capacité à conduire des R
forme complexe qui permettent à la fois
l'acquisition de droits nouveaux et la
préservation de notre trajectoire
financière elle démontre qu'il est
possible d'avancer d'améliorer la vie de
nos concitoyens sans dégrader les
déficits au-delà de ces deux mesures
nous avons plus largement eu le souci
d'enrichir le texte à l'Assemblée à
partir des propositions des
parlementaires nous avons ainsi sur
proposition du groupe des Républicains
sécuriser l'affiliation des commissaires
au comptes au dispositif spécifique de
la Caisse nationale des professionnels
libéraux pour l'assurance vieillesse et
les indemnités journalières mal maladie
les mécanismes de clause de sauvegarde
visant à réguler les dépenses de
produits de santé ont également été
retouchés sur la base d'amendement de la
majorité des républicains dans la partie
3 le texte sur lequel le gouvernement a
engagé sa responsabilité reprend
plusieurs propositions transpartisan
dont l'élargissement de la campagne de
vaccination contre le papioma virirus
aux jeunes qui sont accueillis dans les
établissements médicauxsoaux qui a fait
l'objet d'amendement du groupe
socialiste et du groupe les républicains
la prise en compte des bilans de santé
réalisé à l'entrée dans les dispositifs
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance pour
faciliter le repérage précoce des
situations de handicap dans le cadre des
nouvelles plateformes créées par le
PLFSS suite au dépôt d'amendements pour
par les républicains le Parti socialiste
le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine et les
écologistes la suppression de l'article
39 relatif à l'indemnisation des
accidents du travail et des maladies
professionnelles comme l'ont demandé les
différents groupes de l'Assemblée
nationale en plein accord avec les
partenaires sociaux qui vont y
retravailler nous avons aussi retenu des
amendements qui avaient été déposés par
les groupes de la majorité en commission
des affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale et qui ont été adopté je pense
à la généralisation du dépistage du CO
mégalovirus pendant la grossesse et aux
mesures d'ajustement des financements de
certaines activités hospitalières par
exemple la dialyse et la radiothérapie
le PLFSS que nous présentons dans sa
version enrichie à l'Assemblée donc tout
à la fois un texte créateur de droit
nouveau un texte qui investit
massivement dans la santé et nos
politiques sociales mais aussi qui Assur
la soutenabilité à long terme du système
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci monsieur le ministre je pense que
nos rapporteurs vont avoir quelques
questions à vous poser au regard de la
présentation qui est faite je vrais
simplement moi en préambule vous
apporter une petite remarque en matière
de méthode notamment c'est sur
l'actualisation des annexes financières
qui est toujours pour nous un exercice
particulier puisque nous sommes à une
semaine de de l'examen en en en
commission du PLFSS et l'actualisation
ne dépend pas uniquement des évolutions
à l'Assemblée nationale l'actualisation
elle correspond à un travail de fond et
voilà et j'avoue que je suis toujours un
peu gêné de récupérer ces informations
très peu de temps avant l'examen voilà
ce qui fait partie en tout cas des des
remarques sur la capacité à avoir des
informations en Bonet du forme pour
pouvoir juger des évolutions proposé
voilà donc je donne tout de suite la
parole à ellisabeth
douanau merci Monsieur le prés président
merci monsieur le ministre pour
l'ensemble de ces propos liminires en
même temps j'ai un doute je me demande
si on parle de la même trajectoire sur
les déficits parce que quand vous dites
maîtrise moi j'ai le sentiment que quand
on regarde là à partir de 2025 ça
augmente sérieusement et je vois pas
l'ombre d'une maîtrise et en tout cas du
remboursement de la dette sociale j'ai
plusieurs questions d'abord sur la revue
de dépenses l'article 17 du projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques prévoit que des économies
issues du dispositif de revue de
dépenses représentent 6 milliards
d'euros par an j'ai eu l'occasion de de
le dire plusieurs fois c'est sur les
années de 2025 à 2027 et sont répartis
entre les dépenses des administrations
de sécurité sociale d'abord la la
rédaction du rapport annexé au projet de
cette loi suggère qu'il ne s'agira pas
de réaliser 6 milliards d'euros
d'économie supplémentaire chaque année
mais euh on maintient ces 6 milliards
d'euros euh c'est réalisé en 2025 elles
sont maintenues les années suivantes
est-ce que vous confirmer ce point euh
et a-t-on une idée de la manière dont
ces 6 milliards d'euros doivent se
répartir entre les régimes obligatoires
de base et les autres administrations de
sécurité sociale parce que on a très
très peu de détails hein on nous annonce
des économies un chiffre mais on sait
pas trop euh
euh quels en seront vraiment euh les les
comment les répartitions sur les
prévisions d'excédent des régimes
complémentaires de retraite le projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publicque prévoit dans son rapport
annexé que l'excédent des régimes
complémentaires de retraite actuellement
de 0,3 points de PIB soit 10 milliards
d'euros quand même restera à ce niveau
jusqu'en 2027 pourtant les prévisions à
l'horizon 2037 alors c'est vrai que
c'est loin récemment transmise par
laagir Carco à la Commission prévoit un
déficit technique permanent au moins
jusqu'en 2000 37 cet objectif d'excédent
des régimes complémentaires d'environ 10
milliards d'euros en 2027 est-il
toujours d'actualité alors que l'agir
Carco représente actuellement 80 % des
dépenses des régimes complémentaires et
de leurs excédents si oui comment pr
voyez-vous d'y parvenir sur le
financement de de la dette sociale la
loi du 7 août 2020 qui était relative à
la dette sociale et à l'autonomie a
autorisé le transfert de 136 milliards
d'euros de dett de l'URSAF caisse
nationale à laacad
il ressort des montants déjà transférés
qu'il n'est plus possible de transférer
que
8,8 milliards d'euros en 2024 si rien
n'était fait les déficits
s'accumuleraient à l'URSAF caisse
nationale quel encs maximal de dette
l'URSAF caisse nationale peut-elle selon
vous gérer dans de bonnes conditions et
quelles seraient en fait les
conséquences concrètes d'une
accumulation de dettes au-delà de ce
seuil qu'est-ce que le gouvernement
prévoit de faire pour sécuriser le
financement de la dette sociale
prévoit--il par exemple de modifier
l'article 4 bis de l'ordonnance de 96
pour repousser une nouvelle fois
l'échéance d'amortissement qui était
actuellement fixée à
2033 un dernier point sur la fiscalité
nutritionnelle je pense que c'est un mob
un levier mobilisé dans plusieurs pays
par contre la France est nettement en
retard sur ce plan-là alors qu'il
permettrait de dégager des recettes
nouvelles en France seul les boissons
sucré et d'ulcoré font l'objet d'une
taxation spécifique avisé comportemental
cette taxation a rapportter 600 millions
d'euros en 2022 en juillet 2023 le
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
recommandait notamment de réformer la
fiscalité actuelle sur les boissons
sucrées et édulcoré en augmentant les
barêmes de contribution sur ces produits
et d'étudier l'extension de cette
fiscalité aux produits sucrés ou
contenant des additifs nocifs pour la
santé est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
monsieur le ministre une telle mesure
fait l'objet de travaux du gouvernement
et est-ce que des hypothèses ont été
étudiées et chiffré en terme de recette
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre je
vous laisse répondre à notre rapporteur
général avant de donner la parole aux
autres sénateurs très bien alors
euh s'agissant des
mesures d'économie structurelle dans la
loi de programmation sur les finances
publiques vous savez qu'on a globalement
la nécessité de trouver 12 milliards
d'euros d'économie euh toutes à pu come
on dit d'ici 2025 12 milliards d'euros
d'économie structurelle qui se
répartissent entre 6 milliards pour
l'État et 6 milliards pour le champ
assaut dont la sécurité sociale on n'a
pas défini de sous-objectifs euh et à ce
stade c'est bien l'exercice que nous
avons relancé avec la première ministre
de revue de de dépenses qui doit nous
permettre de documenter ces réformes
donc ces réformes elles ne sont pas
connues euh à cette heure puisque c'est
le travail que nous menons on prépare
dès maintenant le budget euh 2000 2025
et c'est bien tout l'objectif du travail
qui a été euh qui a été engagé mais je
préfère le dire euh ici euh le niveau
d'économie attendue est un niveau
ambitieux à la fois pour le champ euh de
la sécurité sociale et puis pour le
champ de de l'État donc il faut qu'on on
aille assez loin dans la revue des la
revue des euh la revue des dépenses
comme la première ministre la l'a
annoncé mais pas de répartition à ce
stade des des
montants sur la question de notamment de
la
dette la dette la dette URSAF transférée
à la à la
cadè et notamment la capacité à
continuer à l'amortir alors vous savez
que euh d'abord j'aurais pu commencer
par là la trajectoire elle est
effectivement dégradée pardon j'aurais
pu commencer par là quand on voit que
déficit de la sécurité sociale en 2027
sera de 17 milliards d'euros ce déficit
j'en conviens avec vous il est important
et et moi je défends comme ministre des
comptes publics qu'un système qui n'est
pas financé est un système en danger et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on
s'attèle je dirais avec beaucoup
d'ambition à ce programme de revue des
dépenses parce qu'il est indispensable
pour nous de continuer à identifier des
mesures non pas de baisse comme
j'entends parfois de de la dépense mais
de maîise de la dépense pour
maîtriser et garantir le le financement
de notre régime
s'agissant du du de la dette dite
sociale chaque année la cadè amorti
entre 15 et et 20 milliards d'euros elle
amorti d'ailleurs plus que le déficit de
de la
CQ il reste
91 9 milliards de dett pardon que l'on
peut transférer à la cadè et les futurs
déficits seront donc maintenus à la CSE
sait aussi que dans la période d covid
la COS a déjà géré un haut niveau
d'endettement et que pour l'année qui
arrive 2024 nous n'avons aucune
inquiétude aucune inquiétude et qu'on
travaille naturellement pour ajuster nos
outils et rendre finançable et
soutenable la dette sociale au sens
large c'est un travail que que que l'on
mène et qui est en cours mais il n'y a
naturellement aucune inquiétude pour
l'année 2024 et on regarde avec
attention
les années les années qui viennent
peut-être j'aurais pu répondre en
introduction à votre votre
interpellation sur le fait que pour
l'actualisation des annexes du PLFSS se
fait tardivement mais c'est vrai qu'on
est dans un calendrier que que vous
connaissez on a pris l'engagement de le
faire avant la séance publique pour
pouvoir intégrer les nouvelles données
au au PLFSS euh les grands équilibres y
compris euh euh le texte arrêté P1 P2 P3
c'est fait il y a il y a quelques jours
donc on fait et je peux vous dire que
les services sont extrêmement mobilisé
pour éclairer du mieux possible la
représentation nationale et vous donner
toujours dans les meilleurs délis toutes
les informations qui euh qui vous
permettre euh de euh de vous prononcer
un mot sur la fiscalité euh
comportementale
euh et ça c'est le minise des comptes
public qui qui vous le dit nous on a
pris un engagement de pas augmenter les
pas augmenter les les impôts pas
augmenter les impôts donc euh ça passe
aussi pour les sujets de fiscalité
comportementale au moment où on se bat
pour le pouvoir d'achat on fait au
moment où on se bat sur le pouvoir
d'achat euh on ne souhaite pas grever le
pouvoir d'achat des Français avec une un
alourdissement de de de la fiscalité et
la position que je défends avec ma
casquette souvent je le dis tout au
risque de de susciter un peu de débat
dans dans dans cette enceinte tous les
problèmes de politique publique ne
trouvent pas leur réponse à travers la
fiscalité je vous donne je vous donne un
exemple il y a des politiques de
prévention de lutte contre les
addictions qui ne passe pas
nécessairement par l'arme j'allais dire
fiscale donc il faut qu'on puisse
utiliser tous les leviers tout en tenant
notre engagement que nous avons pris
devant les Français de ne pas alourdir
de ne pas alourdir la la fiscalité merci
Monsieur le Ministre alors je vais
donner la parole à Jean-Marie van
lorenberg merci monsieur le
Président bon monsieur le ministre merci
de votre intervention et des précisions
que vous avez apporté sur les comptes je
rejoins l'inquiétude de la rapporteur
générale sur les doutes
euh concernant la la soutenabilité à
long terme du système je reprends ces
termes je pense que quand vous avez des
déficits de 9 milliards l'assurance
maladie qui continue jusqu'en 2027 6
milliards qui croit sur l'assurance
vieillesse jusqu'à 14 milliards en 2027
expliquez-moi comment vous allez
résoudre cela euh rapidement alors vous
me dites on y
travaille je veux bien le croire hein je
ne mets pas en doute effectivement ce
travail il me il m'aurait paru utille
que vous en donniez quelques vous nous
donniez quelques informations quelques
piste sur les propositions que
détaillées que vous comptez
effectivement travailler je vais vous
donner quelques pistes pour ma
part que les uns et les autres ici
connaissent très bien sont les fraudes
les fraudes sociales sur les fraudes
sociales vous faites un petit effort il
y a eu une lettre de mission de vos
prédécesseurs et de Monsieur du SOP
toujours en poste aussi mais qui a
changé de ministère euh qui précise à
chaque qui demande plus exactement à
chaque
caisse de sécurité sociale de fournir
effectivement une estimation précise de
la fraude qui est constaté et sur
lesquel évidemment il doiv faire des
propositions euh
de de de de de rattrapage quoi
évidemment de récupération alors je
constate que un certain nombre de
caisses on fait ce travail mais
l'assurance maladie l'assurance maladie
est en retard prétextant que c'est
complexe je veux bien le croire c'est
complexe mais ça fait 2 ans qu'on nous
dit que c'est en retard et que ça ça va
être difficile d'y arriver alors que il
s'agit de 250
milliards que les
estimations corroboré d'ailleurs par la
Cour des comptes parle de 2 et demi à 6
% des de
fraude suivant effectivement les les
professions ça nous donne un chiffre
approximatif d'une dizaine de
milliards d'économie à opérer rien que
sur la fraude à l'assurance
maladie vous avez les fraudes à la
cotisation cotisation deursaf la Cour
des comptes a livré un chiffre 6 à 8
milliards que d'ailleurs n'a jamais
contesté
l'URSAF mais que fait-on effectivement
de façon intensive volontariste pour
résoudre ces ce sont des vrais problèmes
il y a des pistes là conséquentes pour
faire des économies on n plus à
rechercher un milliard là on est à
plusieurs plusieurs milliards voire 10
15 20 milliards alors écoutez je je
doute de la
volonté je doute de la volonté de
certaines CAES je parle pas du ministre
je parle mais mais le ministre il est là
pour exiger qu'il ait des réponses
conséquentes à la circulaire plus que
circulaire d'ailleurs à la lettre de
mission qui a été cossigné par le
Premier ministre à l'époque bon donc
première chose il faut être plus
ambitieux il y a un autre sujet vous
l'avez évoqué la pertinence des soins ou
des actes écoutez l'OCDE dit 25 % de
soins redondant inutiles on l'a a
vérifié ici plusieurs fois dans des
auditions
euh la la ministre de la Santé madame
Buzin avait totalement totalement
corroborer ce chiffre en disant
effectivement il y a un travail qui est
fait avec Laah
ouais c'est ça sur la pertinence des
soins sur les bonnes pratiques et cetera
moi je dis c'est insuffisant on a
auditionné la présidente de la hasas
j'ai entendu son directeur présent à cet
cet entretien euh dire toute façon
faites pas d'illusion monsieur le
sénateur on n'arrivera pas avec les
médecins à récupérer ces
25% je dis je vous parle pas de
récupérer 25 % d'emblé d'un coup mais de
faire l'effort pour aller dans ce sens
pour ça il faut prendre les moyens faut
prendre des dispositions faut mettre des
moyens de contrôle mettre des investir
dans le contrôle c'est gagner
effectivement c'est un investissement
productif vous en conviendrez donc pour
moi on ne fait pas l'effort nécessaire
alors qu'il y a là des milliards à aller
glanner avant de penser effectivement à
trouver chez les les les les salariés
les sommes correspondantes et puis
dernière piste si vous voulez bien c'est
concernant la vieillesse bon j'avais
proposé ça n'a pas été voté ça n'a pas
été accepté par ni le gouvernement ni
d'ailleurs le Sénat je le regrette c'est
qu'on augmente la cotisation entreprise
parce que l'effort qui a été demandé aux
entreprises sur le pour la vieillesse
n'a pas été conséquent pour pas dire
pratiquement pour le moment égal à zéro
puisque sur les seniors on attend
toujours effectivement les suitees des
propositions qui ont été faites et des
décisions qui ont été prises donc pour
moi augmenter d'un
demi-po ça représente 300 € par salarié
par an une entreprise de 5 salariés vous
demanderez un vice-président la C PME
qui a 5 salariés ce que ça représente
1500 € par an par
salarié 1500 € par an pour son
entreprise pardon avec les 300 € par an
par salarié c'est peu je dis ça met pas
votre entreprise en faillite et par
contre ça
constituait si on l'appliquait à toutes
les entreprises et au 30 millions de
salariés ça ça représente 4 milliards et
demi de recettes 4 milliard et demi un
demi point de cotisation en plus on peut
d'ailleurs être plus progressif hein on
peut commencer par 025 points et cetera
puis bon donc c'est une piste et euh
comme je sais que vous avez appliqué une
doxa qui est très claire on n'augmente
pas les impôts je vais vous livrer une
petite idée parce que j'ai entendu
parler d'un swap possible à avec sur les
cotisations avec la GIR
Carco pourquoi pas à une condition c'est
que ça soit négocié avec les partenaires
sociaux parce que je tiens beaucoup et
nous tenons beaucoup notre groupe au
paritarisme je dis pourquoi pas au moins
temporairement je pense que il y a des
pistes qui sont je dirais qui peuvent
être effectivement conséquente et
fructueuse voilà ce que je vous l merci
Cath pouropouli merci monsieur le
Président bonjour monsieur le
ministre merci alors moi je ne suis
absolument pas convaincu par ce que vous
nous avez dit moi d'abord j'ai une
petite question je voudrais
savoir qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
pertinence des soins je j'ai une
interrogation sur pertinence des soins
euh je ne vois pas ce que vous avez
voulu dire dans votre propos sur la
pertinence des soins donc je me permets
de vous interroger deuxièmement moi
aussi j'ai une petite suggestion à vous
faire pour vous faire faire euh euh des
économies dans le budget de la sécurité
sociale vous savez que la part des
cotisations sociales dans les recettes
de la sécurité sociale est passé de 90 %
à à la fin des années 80 à 50 % depuis
2019 ne pensez-vous pas qu'il vous
faudrait agir pour donc et bien avoir
des parts de cotisation sociale qui soi
plus juste et donc pour enflouer les
recettes de la sécurité sociale et je
dois dire que vous avez une tente euh
dans vos propos c'est le transfert
précipité comme à chaque fois du
recouvrement des cotisation à GIR Carco
vers
l'URSAF donc c'est c'est constant de de
votre part même si on change de ministre
on ne change pas au moins de constante
sur ça et vous savez vous savez qu'il y
a quand même des difficultés techniques
que nous avions mis en avant renonc oui
alors vous y avez renoncé
vous y avez renoncé
mais pas tout à fait parce que à chaque
fois on a ce letre motif qui revient
vous y avez renoncé peut-être pour cette
année mais vous suivez cette ambition
quand même de faire en
sorte que donc les cotisations à GIR
Carco soi transféré vers l'URSAF euh
voilà donc j'aimerais savoir si c'est
définitive ou si finalement euh vous
allez nous remettre sur le tapis euh non
pas à ce budget à ce PLFSS mais par la
suite ce
transfert donc des cotisations sociales
de la Jer Carco vers l'URSAF qui nous
inquiète évidemment toujours beaucoup
merci merci beaucoup Chantal de Scine
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord je veux m'excuser
auprès de vous si je ne peux pas être
présent lors de votre réponse nous
sommes le 31 octobre et je suis tribut
des trains voilà j'ai deux questions à
vous poser concernant la branche
autonomie la branche autonomie et nous
en avons parlé précédemment avec la
ministre berger vers au département 12
concours financiers pour un montant
total de 4 milliards d'euros c'est assez
complexe comme système et les
départements la
CNSA les représentants du secteur
médico-social sont favorables à une à
une une réforme et je voudrais que vous
nous disiez ce qui fait actuellement
obstacle à la mise en place de cette
réforme et puis la 2è question ça
concerne la
fusion section soins et section
dépendance quels seront les les
modalités de la compensation financière
des départements à partir du moment où
les départements auront opté pour la
fusion et est-ce que les dép appartement
auront bien tous les critères et toutes
les informations nécessaires pour
pouvoir opter éventuellement pour cette
fusion je vous
remercie merci beaucoup alors l'audition
est enregistrée donc on pourra comme ça
consulter la réponse voilà Olivier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le le ministre un certain nombre de
questions a été posées notamment par mon
collègue Jean-Marie van
lorenberg fait attention
maintenant euh mais mais tout de même
j'ai si vous voulez le j'ai le le
sentiment que c'est une forme de de
PLFSS de transition hein c'est-à-dire
que on aborde une période différente sur
le plan de économique et sur le plan
financier c'est-à-dire qu'on a connu une
période où le le il n'y avait pas
d'inflation l'argent était pas cher
parfois les taux d'intérêt étaient même
négatifs on avait eu monsieur hangard
dans une audition ça m'avait beaucoup
marqué qui euh nous avait dit qu'il y
avait une provision positive parce que
euh la cosse avait beaucoup emprunté euh
évidemment on n'est plus du tout dans
cette période làà et il me semble qu'on
n anticipe pas beaucoup cette cette
période de de changement économique de
d'augmentation des des taux et donc euh
voir un peu alors vous avez abordé la
trajectoire 2025 mais durablement avec
ce changement économique avec Monsieur
hangard nous l'a dit l'autre fois quand
on a on l'a auditionné est sur la CA 80
% de notre dette qui est financée par
les marchés sur les marchés et donc
durablement c'est pas soutenable
exprimer voir un peu quel est votre
vision par rapport à à ce PLFSS et puis
avoir une situation un peu paradoxale
qui est la mienne c'est d'être
rapporteur de la branche famille qui
elle est excédentaire alors selon vous
est-ce qu'elle est excédentaire parce
que quelle est votre lecture est-ce que
les recettes sont moins sont sont mal
calibrés est-ce que c'est un manque de
volonté politique de de comment
voyez-vous les choses comme ministre des
comptes publics et puis également est-ce
que vous avez déjà une lecture sur
l'impact que aura malheureusement hein
pense que on va pas corriger le tir tout
de suite la baisse de la natalité dans
notre pays je vous remercie merci
beaucoup Corine
Ambert merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Ministre alors pardonnez-moi
si je suis un petit peu longue mais la
branche paladie pèse presque 255000
milliard d'euros euh et donc j'ai
plusieurs questions à vous poser je vais
bien sûr commencer par par l'ondame euh
vous nous demandez de rétablir et de
modifier l'ondame 2023 et d'approuver
celui pour 2024 pouvez-vous préciser les
hypothèses sur lesquelles sont établir
les prévisions pour 2024 et comment a
été révisée la base pour 2023 euh les
prévisions du gouvernement semblent
largement éloigné des besoins effectifs
des établissements de santé le ministre
votre collègue Aurélien Rousseau nous a
dit que le gouvernement et je cite ne
laisserait pas les hôpitaux dans le
rouge à la fin de l'année alors que le
déficite des hôpitaux publics atteint 1
milliard d'euros comment le gouvernement
compte-il effectivement couvrir les
conséquences de l'inflation pour les
établissements est-ce que cela relèvera
de crédits nouveaux et est-ce qu'ils
seront annoncés au Sénat et
serveront-ils de base pour 2024 ou
est-ce que ça va être un petit tour de
passe-pe et et uniquement le fait d'un
déblocage du gel prudentiel
deuxè question autour de de landam donc
je vous le disais nous allons presque
atteindre 255 milliards d'euros 254,9
exactement votre collègue Aurélien
Rousseau disait devant la commission la
semaine dernière qu'il fallait que
l'ONDAM revienne à ce qu'il doit être
alors ma question est assez simple
comment l'ONDAM peut-il redevenir un
instrument de pilotage et effectivement
une norme de dépenses est-ce que les
instruments de prévision de la Direction
de la Sécurité sociale sont-ils dépassé
ou pas ou est-ce que les dépenses sont
devenues ingérables et enfin une deux
autres petites questions concernant
longam euh comment faire de longam un
moment de sanction alors c'est pas être
une sanction positive ou négative he une
sanction parlementaire de l'autorisation
des dépenses publiques euh quand
monsieur le ministre construirez-vous
des sous-objectifs qui ne dépassent pas
et C cas pour deux d'entre eux 100
milliards d'euros est-ce qu'à un moment
donné on pourrait avoir une vision un
peu plus affinée de ces dépenses le le
sousobjectif soins de ville et le
sousobjectif hôpital c'est plus de 100
milliards d'euros est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à faire voter les parlementaires
comme nous le demandions hein lors de la
révision de la loi Lovs de la Lovs
pardon les sur nous faire voter sur les
dotations qui relève pas du
remboursement de prestation sociale et
puis au début de vos propos vous
avez annoncé avoir mis dans le texte qui
arrive au Sénat des mesures introduites
à l'Assemblée nation nationale moi je
constate que l'ondame a le même montant
alors évidemment ce sont peut-être des
dépenses qui se chiffrent à des dizaines
de millions d'euros donc qui
n'apparaissent pas mais de combien est
dégradé l'ONDAM et de combien est
dégradé le déficit de la branche maladie
avec l'introduction de ces mesures
introduites à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
ensuite trois autres questions si vous
me permettez d'abord l'une sur la
réforme de du financement des activités
de médecine de chirurgie et
d'obstétrique une une réforme et une
mesure qui avrait pas coûteuse donc si
elle est pas coûteuse ça veut dire qu'il
va y avoir des gagnants et des perdants
qui seront les gagnants et qui seront
les
perdants une question sur l'article 27
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui vise à réguler les
dépenses d'indemnité journalière
maladie donc le ministre a dit qu'il
était ouvert à la discussion sur cet
article et qu'il n'était pas certain
qu'il faille porter symboliquement et
politiquement la
responsabilité de l'explosion des sur le
patient est-ce que vous partagez cet
avis et enfin une question sur une
disposition qui n'est pas dans le texte
mais dont on on a beaucoup parlé qui
concerne les franchises médicales on en
a beaucoup parlé au moment juste avant
la présentation du PLFSS quelles sont
les intentions réelles du Gouvernement
en la matière landendam 2024 est-il bien
assis sur une hypothèse d'augmentation
de ces franchises et participation
forfaitair pour un rendement de 800
millions d'euros 800 millions d'euros
rapporté au 3 milliards 5 d'effort
d'économi que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure donc important de de nous
préciser cela et pourquoi ne pas avoir
préféré un report sur l'assurance
maladie complémentaire plutôt qu'une
franchise qui ne peut être couverte par
ces dernières en tout cas pourquoi ne
pas avoir soumis cette mesure à la
représentation nationale même si
j'entends bien qu'à partir du moment où
il y a pas une nouvelle franchise il
n'est pas obligé de passer par la loi et
que ça peut être du du ressort du
règlementaire je vous remercie merci
pour cet ensemble de questions allez et
pour terminer Monsieur le Ministre
dernière intervenante c'est Annie
louou voilà je vais essayer d'être
rapide concernant la branche famille qui
est excédentaire le PLFSS prévoit une
augmentation des prestations familiales
seulement à compter du 1er avril 2024
cette date est considéré comme tardive
pour prendre en compte notamment les
effets inflation dont subis par les
familles le Haut Conseil de la famille
et de l'enfance et de l'âge suggère
pardon un
une indexation des prestations en cas de
dépassement de l'inflation de 2
% de donc à comptter de la dernière
revalorisation est-ce que cette
proposition est à l'étude et est-ce
qu'elle a une chance d'aboutir et puis
dernière remarque euh vous vous enfin
vous avez dit à plusieurs reprises que l
motif de ne pas augmenter les impôts
mais je me pose la question de du fait
que ce soit raisonnable à un moment
où les la Fédération hospitalière de
France réclame 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour les hôpitaux qu'on
a parlé tout à l'heure longuement des
éepades qui sont en en grande difficulté
et que le vieillissement suppose un
investissement et un accompagnement des
familles y compris au niveau financier
je m'interroge sur le fait que l'ondame
et que ce budget qui nous est proposé ne
soit pas sincère merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre je vous laisse
répondre un ensemble de questions
technique
euh monsieur le monsieur le sénateur
vanler Renberg je l'ai
bien pas mal pour une première c'est pas
mal bon ok j'ai le même problème non non
non mais je
euh comment on fait vous disiez bon il y
a une situation de déficite on voit les
perspectives
qui sont des perspectives où ce déficite
bien qu'on a réussi à à revenir sur une
période d covid où on réduit le déficit
de manière un peu structurel dans dans
ce projet loi de financement de la
sécurité
sociale on porte le sujet des économies
quand même
3,5 milliards d'euros d'économie je je
l'ai je les ai détaillé dans mon propos
liminire et ça c'est la conviction qui
est la notre c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
continuer à avoir un système protecteur
mais que la question des économies
elle est aussi légitime pour garantir la
protection à long terme et un haut
niveau de service et une sécurité
sociale de qualité on l'a fait en 24
avec des sujets autour de des dépenses
de de de de produits de santé notamment
mais aussi déficience à l'hôpital la
politique des achats donc c'est un
ensemble de mesures et on doit continuer
abattir ces mesures qui vont nous
permettre de faire des des économies
est-ce que vous avez d'autres pistes moi
par exemple je suis très attaché au fait
qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin sur la
prescription à l'unité des médicaments
je suis frappé du gaspillage qui existe
que les uns les autres on peut constater
dans notrre propres armoires à pharmacie
alors moi j'entends les difficultés des
uns des autres je vois ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays y compris en
garantissant la traçabilité on est
capable est-ce qu'on est capable de
prescrire la la
juste la juste dose le nombre de
médicaments pour éviter de gaspiller
autant de médicaments dans notre pays
voilà donc je pense qu'il y a un sujet
il y a un sujet autour j'allais dire de
la logistique et de l'industrialisation
de la fabrication on a un sujet autour
de la prescription la prescription quand
même la prescription quand je regarde le
rapport qui a été remis qui nous a été
remis qui s'appelle pour un New Deal
j'ai plus exactement le le titre exact
mais qui évoque des sujets autour des
budgets prescription des professionnels
de
santé disant est-ce que comme dans
d'autres pays en Allemagne par exemple
on regarde en fonction de la typologie
de la patientelle de son âge la
localisation géographie et on regarde à
peu près les volumes de prescription
est-ce que dans la l'ouverture de la
négociation
conventionnelle conduite par le ministre
de la Santé on peut avec les
professionnels de santé s'engager sur
des mesures de régulation prescription
des dépenses de médicaments dépenses de
médicament progresse de 4 % chaque année
quand même et si on veut continuer à
couvrir les protocoles les les les plus
coûteux les plus innovants pour apporter
mais finalement plus de chance aux
malades il faut aussi qu'on arrive à
faire des économies là là où on peut
donc donc oui oui on doit faire des
économies le sujet des indemnités
journalières j'y reviendrai bon on a on
a un champ très large qu'il nous faut
explorer bon alors sur la fraude non sur
la fraude sociale ce PLFSS comme le PLF
d'ailleurs propose déjà un certain
nombre de mesures importantes mais mais
je vais revenir parce que je je je suis
moi disposé à travailler avec vous à
écouter vos propositions parce que je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin mais
quand même rappelons-nous que nous avons
dans le PLF le PLFSS une mesure pour
mieux sécuriser le crédit d'impôt
Service à la Personne les prélèvements
de cotisation sur les travailleurs des
plateformes que les caisses de sécurité
sociale se sont engagé sur un
recrutement de 1000 TP d'ici 2027 dédié
à la lutte contre la fraude sociale moi
je pense qu' il en va de notre sociale
et donc il y a un véritable effort et
une orientation qui a été fixée aux
caises de sécurité sociale de renforcer
la lutte contre la fraude on introduit
dans le PLFSS un délit d'incitation à la
fraude sociale par parallélisme avec ce
qu'on fait dans le champ fiscal
d'ailleurs en disant ceux qui vivent qui
font de la promotion de la frudte
sociale c'est un coup de canif dans
notre contrat social et il faut pouvoir
traiter la fraude à la source il faut
qu'on soit intransigeent sur ce sujetlà
et donc chacune des caisses de sécurité
sociale a des plans d'action C même des
moyens renforcés pour mieux lutter
contre la fraude j'ai installé madame la
la rapporteur
générale y était autour du Conseil
d'évaluation de de la fraude en disant
il faut qu'on évalue mieux on a cert des
rapports de la Cour des comptes mais
c'est parfois difficile d'évaluer
correctement le montant de la FRUD et
pour être efficace dans notre politique
de lutte contre la fraude il faut qu'on
y voit plus clair et c'est tout le
mandat que nous avons fixé aux
administration dans le cadre du Conseil
d'évaluation de la fraude et on
reviendra
avant non il manque honnêtement il
manque on a des des trous dans la
raquette très important et et d'ailleurs
le l'assurance maladie était là pour
mieux évaluer le le le montant de la
frude il y a un travail à à à conduire
et je suis par ailleurs ouvert à toutes
les propositions des parlementaires sur
ce sujetl on a mis dans le PLF dans le
PLFSS moi je suis prêt à porter un
projet loi dédié à la lutte contre la
fraude si on voit qu'il manque des
dispositifs législatifs pour le musc cl
et je serais très très très très à
l'écoute des propositions de la
Commission des sénateurs sur sur ce
sujet-là voilà sur sur sur la fraudte
sociale j'en ai parlé sur les les les
dispositifs médicaux je vous ai un peu
répondu on fait des économies et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on fait un
milliard de baisse de prix quand même he
et qu'on va faire des économies sur les
sur les volumes à hauteur de 300
millions d'euros avec des sujets très
concrets avec ce qu'on appelle les trod
mais je pense que le ministre la santé
vous en a parlé sur les engines sur les
cystites euh j'insiste sur la
prescription à l'unité en cas de risque
de rupture d'approvisionnement moi je
suis convaincu donc qu'on pour le faire
dans d'autres cas de figure ce sont de
bons instruments de régulation euh de de
la
dépense euh en revanche sur la
cotisation entreprise là je ne vous suis
pas pourquoi je pourquoi je ne vous suis
pas c'est que non mais pourquoi je
pourquoi je je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi moi je crois qu'un un un un des
un des leviers euh très important pour
nous pour garantir euh la viabilité la
pérenité de notre modèle social c'est le
niveau d'emploi le niveau d'activité
donc la croissance tout ce qui empute
d'une manière ou d'une autre
l'incitation à la création d'activité le
soutien à la création
d'emploi joue finalement contre le
redressement de de de de nos de nos de
nos finances social moi je regarde
depuis 2017 on a créé 2 millions
d'emplois supplémentaires et on l'a créé
grâce à notre activité économique et
parce qu'on a assumé des politiques de
baisse d'impôt qui nous permettent
d'ailleurs de paradoxalement parfois en
disant on baisse les impôts mais en fait
c'est bon pour les finances publiques et
donc je suis très vigilant quand on veut
augmenter les cotisations entreprise
parce que l'objectif c'est pas
d'accroître le coût du le coût du
travail parce que je pense qu'il faut
continuer à inciter les entreprises à
créer le plus d'emplois d'emploi
possible
euh
madame pouli voilà je je je vous
chercher sur la pertinence des soins
c'est un peu la la réflexion qu'on doit
ouvrir je l'évoqué par exemple sur les
budgets de prescription sur comment
est-ce qu'on travaille avec les les les
professionnels de santé se poser la
question de la juste prescription du
mieux de prescription et parfois de
moins de prescription je pense notamment
au
médicaments ob non mais pas pas
seulement mais je suis là sur parce que
là on a reçu par exemple des
propositions des propositions concrètes
notamment de du rapport qui nous a été
remis je pense qu'il faut qu'on continue
à travailler sur sur ce sujet-l ça nous
aide à maîtriser l'évolution de notre
dépense et je le dis ça veut pas dire
baisser la dépense mais maîtriser la
dépense sur le transfert de recouvrement
j'ai cru vous alliez saluer cette
décision
euh année bon mais bon je vous invite à
la saluer pour les années qui viennent
alors parce que non mais l'objectif
c'est vu de l'entreprise il faut que ces
réseaux il faut que ces réseaux se
parlent
il faut que ce soit une simplification
aussi pour pour les entreprises donc il
y a un enjeu de de de coordination y
compris vu de l'entreprise pour
simplifier leur démarché c'est tout le
travail qui doit être mené entre l'URSAF
et puis l'agir Carco donc voilà je pense
que vous avez été vous avez été
entendu s'agissant m'avait interpelé sur
les concours financiers non c'est c'est
Chantal est parti qui est parti mais je
je lui réponds quand même voilà elle est
là je lui je lui réponds euh oui sur les
12 concours financiers versés au
département c'est un sujet mais qui
nécessite au préalable de mener une
concertation avec les départements voilà
il faut mener cette concertation écouter
les difficultés essayer de bâtir moi il
n'y a aucun je dis à madame la sénatrice
il y a pas de d'obstacle de principe de
notre part la question c'est est-ce
qu'on a un chemin commun avec les
départs appartement et donc c'est tout
le travail qui doit être qui doit être
mené sur la fusion des sections qui est
une véritable attente en terme de
simplification quand même entre les
sections soins les sections hébergement
notamment ce travail là il est en cours
elles seront les modalités de
financement seront précisées dans le PLF
2025 les départements seront informés
pour faire des choix éclairés la voix de
l'expérimentation a été a été retenu et
les concours du de la CNSA au
département nécessitent aussi une
concertation euh ça c'était madame le
Seigne monsieur ho euh oui vous
avez vous êtes là pardon excusez-moi
vous avez raison que l'augmentation des
taux d'intérêt a changé beaucoup de
choses on le vois la charge d'intérêt de
la la dette elle va passer de plus de 40
milliards d'euros cette année juste pour
le budget de l'État à quasiment 75
milliards euh je défends un projet de de
loi de fin de gestion dans lesquel on
doit ouvrir 3,8 milliards d'euros de
plus au titre de de la charge de la
charge d'intérêt donc bien sûr bien sûr
que cela change cela change la donne et
ça exige de nous que l'on soit plus
ambitieux sur les économies sur la
dépense et les économie parce que c'est
autant de marge de manœuvre en moins que
que que que nous avons vous m' appeler
sur la situation de la branche la
branche famille euh notamment al vous
savez l'excédent va diminuer
progressivement euh avec des des mesures
importantes qui ont été qui ont été
prises et que pour encourager euh la
natalité il faut aussi accompagner
l'arrivée des l'arrivée des jeunes
enfants il y a dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 euh des mesures importantes qui ont
été prises pour faciliter le recours aux
assistantes maternelles il y a le
complément mode de garde qui a été
étendu on a revalorisé l'allocation de
soutien familial pour les familles
monoparentales on va indexer les
prestations familiales sur l'inflation
dans ce dans ce projet loi de pour qui
représente plus d'un milliard efforts de
plus d'un milliard d'euros donc voilà il
y a un certain nombre de de mesures et
des sujets sur lesquels la ministre en
charge des solidarités et de la famille
travaille et qu'elle a pu j'imagine vous
exposer dans
l'audition dans l'audition précédente
s'agissant euh de euh long
dame alors s'agissant de long dame euh
et notamment de de l'effet de l'effet
inflation madameber euh il y a
naturellement ça dans dans dans le le
PLF dans le londam 23 prévoyait déjà un
financement des cou liés à l'inflation
les charges non salariales pour 800 800
millions d'euros bon est-ce que on
entend les les fédérations avec le
ministre de la Santé nous dire on a des
problèmes pour boucler nos budgets des
budgets en déficit il y a un travail qui
a été lancé par le ministre de la Santé
avec les fédérations pour bien estimer
et là il est encore trop tôt pour
partager des chiffres l'impact de
l'inflation sur leur situation
financière tenant compte du bouclier
énergétique que l'on a mis en place et
de l'ensemble l'ensemble des mesures qui
ont été qui ont été prises euh est-ce
que l'ondame doit redevenir ce qu'il ce
qu'il doit être je sais pas si un peu
une mise en abîme oui mais partageons
entre nous qu'on a quand même traversé
des périodes
extrêmement qui nous ont bousculé les
uns les autres et que à travers la crise
du covid la crise inflationniste l'ONDAM
lui-même a été un peu bousculé c'est
vrai et moi je souhaite aussi qu'il
redevienne une ancre très importante
dans le pilotage de nos finances
pilotage de nos finances sociales et je
considère qu'avec un nom d'âme qui prog
prress de 3,2 nettement supérieur à
l'inflation il peut redevenir cet ancre
pour nos finances pour nos finances
sociales s'agissant des sous-objectifs
est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin je
vous renvoie déjà dans un premier temps
aux annexes du PLFSS qui vous offre un
niveau de détail un niveau de détail
beaucoup plus important je vois que vous
avez aussi les annexes beaucoup plus
important que les seuls sousobjectifs
parce que je comprends qu'une une une
masse de 100 milliards d'euros tout ça
est un peu agrégé en revanche vous
trouverez dans les annexes de quoi je
crois répondre à répondre à à vos
questions s'agissant des mesures
arrêtées dans le la version de la P3 euh
proposée par le gouvernement il y a peu
d'impact des mesures sur l'ONDAM c'est
pour ça que ça n'a pas été ça n'a pas
été corrigé voilà je crois que c'est
c'est important et par ailleurs sur la
réforme sur la T2A qui est engagé dans
ce PLFSS les études sont en cours avec
les fédérations pour examiner les
gagnants et les perd
ce que ce que vous évoquez et sachant
que la mesure a notamment la dotation he
qui est qui est créée dans le PLFSS elle
a été
largement largement concerté avec les
fédérations
euh sur les is les indemnités
journalières moi je crois qu'il faut
qu'on a un vrai travail ce n'est pas de
la seule responsabilité des salariés
mais il faut qu'on regarde ce sujet de
manière très large et on a invité les
partenaires sociaux à négocier puisque
les se développent elle se développe
parce que il y a un vieillissement de la
population parce que il y a un bon
fonctionnement du marché du travail plus
de salariés mais il y a aussi des
comportements qu'il nous faut regarder
un peu de de près parce que c'est une
dépense qui qui progresse extrêmement
extrêmement
vite et puis j'avais une question de
Madame
leou sur l'inflation notamment dans les
établissement de de santé j'ai commencé
à y répondre on l'avait pris en compte
dès 2022 à hauteur de 8 87 million
d'euros dans l'ONDAM dans l'ONDAM 23 il
y a déjà un financement des couli à
l'inflation sur les charges non
salariales et que ce travail là se
poursuit avec les
fédérations prenez V
micro l'indexation se 1 avril
2024ation familiale qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la proposition
du enfance et la famille qui dit que dès
2 % d'inflation il faut provoquer en
quelque sorte une augmentation des
prestations familiales mais ça c'est
aussi un peu comme le
SMI un certain niveau mécaniquement on
provoque une r bah on a on a une myiade
d'aide d'une certaine manière avec des
règles de revalorisation qui sont
différentes des dates qui sont
différentes dans ce dans ce travail qui
a été engagé sur la solidarité à la sour
c'est aussi redonné de de de la
visibilité et moi je pense que ce
chantier qui une réforme structurelle
importante euh il faut pouvoir se poser
ces questionsl et vous voyez bien que on
est face à un chantier titanesque quand
on regarde l'ensemble de nos de nos
prestations et je pense que c'est ce
beau projet sur lequel le président de
la République s'est engagé devant les
Français en 2020 de de réaliser la
solidarité à la source dans lequel cette
question là doit doit s'intégrer
monsieur ministre je redonne la je
redonne la parole à
corinebert merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre sur les franchises
et les participation forfaitaire je vous
en prie ce n'est pas un acte manqué hein
madame la sénatrice il y a il y a il y a
1,3 milliards d'euros de prévu sur un
ensemble de mesures on a un objectif
qu'on a fixé dans le PLFSS pour lequel
il y a différentes mesures qui sont en
cours de discussion d'instruction qui
peuvent aller de comment je je fais des
économies sur les transports sanitaires
par exemple j'accompagne mieux ceux qui
peuvent partager des véhicules pour
limiter le coût et d'ailleurs son impact
climatique il y a ce travail avec les
les organismes complémentaires on l'a vu
sur les soins dentaires entre régime
général organisme complémentairire il y
a cette réflexion sur les franchises
mais vous savez que c'est pas du niveau
de la loi qu' a des concertations
obligatoires et des discussions OIG ire
et c'est le sens du travail mené
aujourd'hui par le ministre de la Santé
tout ça et ça je le réaffirme devant
nous permettre d'atteindre 1,3 milliard
d'euros
d'économieou allez la dernière question
avant de
clôturer
très bien vous voulez répondre à la
remarque ou non ça sera le mot de la fin
alors non mais non alors je je non si
vous présentez les choses comme ça non
non non non
euh vous dire d'une part que moi je me
suis exprimé sur ce sujet j'aiors de
question que les personnes en affection
de longue durée que les mineur soit
touché ce dispositif qui n'a d'ailleurs
été revu ni par la droite ni par la
gauche depuis qu'il existe qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas été revu dans son montant
non plus voilà on l'a mis on l'a mis
dans le on mis dans le débat mais on ne
peut pas comment dirais-je résumer tout
notre enjeu de maîtrise de la
consommation de médicaments au seul
prisme de la question des franchise il y
a un travail colossal à faire en terme
de prescription avec les professionnels
je le redis qu'il y a un travail de mon
point de vue à faire avec les industriel
sur les prescriptions à l'unité on l'a
vu avec les trotes donc c'est un c'est
un chantier bien plus large qui nous
attend mais vous voulez pas la fiscalité
environnementale et notamment surtout
pas toucher
l'alcool le tabac mais pas l'alcool pour
des questions de pouvoir
d'achat très bien et bien cette fois
c'est moi qui prendrai le mot de la fin
pour vous dire que on pourrait faire un
débat mais c'est pas le lieu avant
l'heure on l'URA dans l'hémicycle en
tout cas merci monsieur le ministre en
tout cas pour vos
réponses et puis je vous souhaite tous
un bon 1er novembre avant de vous
retrouver pour certains jeudi et pour
les autres lundi merci
beaucoup
y